I want to thank the young people who
gave this fight to thank the people from
the popular neighborhoods of Athens an
of other regions series are proved to be
too hard to die even when everyone put
us on the firing line we plead to have
very close ties to the working classes
of people toil and work an electoral
battle has been completed today in which
we fought with seriousness dignity in a
civilized manner the election result
appears to be forming comprehensively
with sarita and mr. tsipras coming first
I congratulate him and calling him to
form the government that is necessary
bring the proposal to Parliament and we
will talk about the rest later there
were other alternative coalition
partners for tsipras I think that's a
really important point passat for
example Fatah me this would have given
tsipras a larger majority with a more
credible party with more competent
administrators I think the choice of the
independent Greeks as a coalition
partner is going to worry the European
simply given what happened over the last
nine months it does raise a question
regarding the government's willingness
and commitment to move forward credibly
with reform
well the next challenges will be to have
the recapitalisation of the banks to be
able to finish the first review to have
a serious discussion about debt and to
be able to provide a parallel program
which addresses some of the real needs
of the Greek people the Greek people
need to see light at the end of the
tunnel if capital controls are not
lifted the small medium enterprises will
keep going under then it's a big problem
for the economy so this government lost
credibility it has to gain it back it
has to do the right thing and very
quickly and it's up to mr. tsipras to
gather together a good team a team that
works hard that has a plan and pushes
the previous government was too late
back to ideological they didn't have a
work ethic they kind of messed up
they trust him to implement his ideas
and people voted with a criterion who's
going to implement the Memorandum of
Understanding or the agreement with our
lenders in them in the way which is
let's say most socially friendly more
more friendly to the citizens